robinson from earlier today talking
about a bust from 2020 in isaiah wilson
we did a lot of work uh a year ago um
leading up to selecting him
um you know the evaluation process
uh talking to you know different sources
visiting with him countless numbers of
times and
um for whatever reason you know the the
player that this this fall was here in
nashville wasn't the guy that was
um that we spent time with last year
so i think you know he's gonna have to
make a determination um if he wants to
do everything necessary to play pro
football
um
and and that's gonna be you know on him
played in one game last year as a team's
first round pick couple of stints on the
covet 19 reserve list some things that
weren't really all that smart
on his part by way of conduct in
connection with the pandemic
and uh one of the so far so far look
there's still plenty chapters left in
every book for every player that was
drafted last year miles but it inspired
by those comments from isaiah wilson
what we're going to do we're going to do
we're going to go back and forth with
one steal and one bust so far this is
not the definitive final word on the
players we're not putting anyone in the
hall of fame we're not putting one
anyone in the fan controlled football
league with johnny manziel so one steal
one bust back and forth miles you're up
first okay well i'm glad that you you
know you presented that in the way that
you did because obviously these things
are subject to change after only one
season but i think that so far the steal
of the 2020 draft has been ram safety
jordan fuller now this guy was a sixth
round pick but he ended up starting 12
games for the los angeles rams he had
three interceptions he had five pass
breakups he picked off tom brady twice
in november the cool thing about that
was he is also the 199th pick in the
draft just like tom brady so i think
that would be a thrill for anybody you
know who is as young as jordan fuller
and has basically been alive as long as
tom brady has been playing football and
winning super bowl so that's one thing
that's pretty cool for him uh my first
bust would then be henry ruggs wide
receiver for the las vegas raiders and
it's because
oh overall pick yeah a bust
look
mike what else am i supposed to say he
was the first wide receiver
he only had 26 catches for 452 yards man
that's not that's bust material after
one year just to i think especially if
you compare him to justin jefferson who
had 1400 yards receiving look i think
that henry ruggs has a chance to grow
and develop but look if you if you're
looking at his production in the first
season no it's not what you expect from
the guy who was the first wide receiver
taken off the board and especially when
he's in somebody's offense like john
gruden and john gruden is known as the
offensive guru he needs to be better and
that is why i think at least for year
one he is a bust mike who are your first
bosses
well and let me just say this about
being a first round receiver especially
the first receiver off the board in a
draft that has plenty of great receivers
it adds extra pressure
and
i agree with you henry ruggs did not
perform to the level that we would
expect
of the first guy taken off the board in
a receiver-rich draft my first steal guy
you've already mentioned justin
jefferson with the vikings rookie
receiving yardage record he was not the
first he was not the second he was not
the third may have been the fourth
receiver off the board there may have
been another one in there by the time
the vikings had a chance to take him i
know he was behind rugs jerry judy no cd
lamb and
and jalen rieger so he was at least the
fourth one off the board at least the
fifth one off the board my mat i just
admit that my math sucks fifth one off
the board justin jefferson was awesome
he was awesome last year and they didn't
really discover what they had in justin
jefferson until week three he could have
had a couple of additional games where
he could end it up with 1600 1700 yards
as a rookie mile so he was great as a
steal
for the vikings in the 20s he should
never have been on the board in the 20s
in hindsight my first bust hey if you're
going to go with a guy who was taking
11th overall is that what he was was the
11th is that what it was i think so the
11th it was between 10 and 15 12. yeah
i'll go with the guy who was fifth
overall i think based on what we've seen
so far too i love tua i love yatua but
joe burrow awesome justin herbert taking
one spot after tua awesome so far i mean
when you need a relief pitcher this is
not baseball when you need a relief
pitcher multiple times
when you supposedly are the guy and they
have to bring in ryan fitzpatrick to
pull the cookies out of the fire that's
not an endorsement of a guy's overall
potential or where he currently is so i
guess look two could turn into a hall of
famer based on what we've seen so far
i don't think he's on track to make it
to canton
oh well no he definitely is not on track
and he was also on my list so that means
i'm gonna have to take somebody else uh
but okay i'm gonna go with another steal
right here that is honestly right up the
alley that you were just there and
that's justin herbert because really if
you're looking at a quarterback and this
guy was picked one spot after tua and he
looks like he probably could be the best
player picked in this particular draft
that's a steal when you get him at sixth
overall and man i'm telling you i look
at justin herbert and i see somebody
that can really be one of these top qb's
and it's gonna be fun to see what these
guys in the afc west can do and can
compete imagine if that trade actually
does happen with the broncos and desean
watson and you've got patrick mahomes
justin herbert deshawn watson nerd car
all in the same division in the afc west
that could be one of the most fun
divisions i think in football and then
i'll stay in the top 10 with my next
bust and part of this is because of
injury but again we're only one season
in here that's going to be jeff akuda
the cornerback from the detroit lions
picked at number three overall and you
know i like i said he was hurt he missed
the last bit of the season but when he
was out there he just didn't look like a
number three overall pick and you've
even got the new coaches there whether
it's defensive coordinator aaron glenn
head coach dan campbell there in detroit
they're all saying man we got to get
jeff aku to play in with some more
confidence you shouldn't need that as a
as the third pick in the draft and as a
cornerback you got to have that stuff
inherently so
again he can become somebody who's great
at quarterback and maybe that's all he
needed was change of coaches mike but i
think at least for right now
he's a bit of a bust at number three
overall from the 2020 draft
and they drafted okuda with the third
overall pick because matt patricia
alienated darius slay right out of the
gates and had to trade him so it became
a need pick at number three instead of
best on the board best on the board at
three was justin herbert i can't say
washington should have taken justin
herbert instead of chase young that
that's that's six or one half a dozen
the other i wouldn't be upset if they
had taken justin herbert because it's a
more important position but
pass rusher is just a half step below
quarterback when it comes to importance
and quarterback plays longer that's why
you get a franchise quarterback you you
you take him you run with him and you
keep him as long as you can but at at
the absolute latest three should have
been the first spot at four the giant
should have taken him instead of andrew
thomas and you trade daniel jones just
like the cardinals traded jeff uh or
josh rosen excuse me and then obviously
tua at five that's gonna torment
dolphins fans and dolphins fans get very
defensive about this like it's okay for
them to be tormented it's not okay for
us to say they should be tormented but
they should be tormented and they likely
are tormented by the fact that the
dolphins took to uh instead of justin
herbert all right next one's for me here
got to get my notes don't want to make
any mistakes
i got to go
well i'm going to i'm going to sandbag
one i'm going to go chase claypool no
with my next one and chase claypool fits
a very important profile for me when it
comes to receivers who become successful
in the nfl i think that a receiver
sliding into round two
is a valuable mindset it's a valuable
motivator it's a valuable chip on the
shoulder michael thomas still driven by
the fact that he was a second round pick
you know you can very easily slip into
that diva mentality as a receiver when
you're a first round pick you don't work
as hard you've arrived when you're a
second round pick and you feel like
you've been slighted you feel like
you've been overlooked you feel like
you've been dissed in some way that
light's a fire that may never go out and
i think we saw some of that with chase
claypool no way he should have lasted as
long as he did on the board and i think
one of the reasons he was so good last
year is because he did last on the board
as long as he did flip it over to bus
territory hey i got to do it i got to do
it now look i understand that
that they they did it
for a strategic reason that may have
been light of fire under aaron rodgers
but i'm sorry you used a first round
pick with a 13-3 team that made it to
the nfc championship he gave up a fourth
round pick to move up to get him and he
never played in a game all year jordan
love based on what we've seen so far was
a waste of a pick by the green bay
packers and if i'm a packers fan and
again they don't want me saying it but
they'll say it to themselves tormented
by what could have been if they had that
first round pick and fourth round pick
two different players two different
lottery tickets on guys who would have
had 18 games under their belts by the
time they played in the nfc championship
and would have been on the field barring
injury contributing to the green bay
packers cause so nothing against jordan
love he may end up being a hall of famer
we don't know but it was a bust of a
pick to use that first round pick and a
fourth to go get him miles yeah he said
based on what we've seen so far it's
absolutely nothing we have no idea
because he didn't even play in a
preseason game because we didn't have
them uh because of the pandemic and
imagine if they would have had t higgins
you know that's somebody who would have
been there on the board another good
young wide receiver all right my next
steal i'm going to go with another guy
who was picked lower on in that draft
that's luxurious snead from the kansas
city chiefs a guy who was a fourth round
pick he started six regular season games
there for the chiefs and then all of
their postseason games but i think he
and that's something that you want out
of somebody who's picked in those lower
rounds and can actually contribute for
you on the team he had two sacks he had
three interceptions in the regular
season he had seven pass breakups and he
had a pair of sacks in the postseason
too so i think when you're talking about
these guys who are young who can show
things on defense like that versatility
you talk about positionless players
sometimes that's what some defensive
coordinators and head coaches in the
league like to talk about i think he's
one of these guys that can really help
this defense continue to take those
steps and be one of these teams that's
not just going to be contending because
of patrick mahomes they've got to have
some good defensive pieces too and i
think he is one of those guys and then
for my last bust i'm going to go with
jaylen rieger all right so this is
another one of these first round wide
receivers and he was picked just one
spot ahead of justin jefferson but
didn't have a game with more than 55
yards and i think definitely some of
this has to do with the qb and the qb
problems that philadelphia had
throughout the entire season but his top
receiving yardage output was 55 yards
and that came in week one when he only
had one catch so when you're talking
about a first round wide receiver you
want more production than that it's very
similar to me with henry ruggs you just
didn't necessarily see it with regor he
had 31 catches 396 yards and 11 games i
i just think that especially when you
see what justin jefferson did a pick
later and who knows what justin
jefferson would have done if he was
playing with carson wentz and jalen
hurts in 2020 but i just think right now
if you're an eagles fan you're
disappointed in the output that you got
there from that pick at 21 overall mike
those are good selections and jaylen
rieger was on my list as well my last
steal has got to be a guy who wasn't
even drafted i mean that counts as a
steal if all the picks went by and his
name was never called and you go get him
as an undrafted free agent that's james
robinson who walks off the street with
no offseason program no preseason to
prove himself wins the starting tailback
job and was awesome as a rookie and now
with trevor lawrence likely to be the
new quarterback in jacksonville james
robinson in position to really flourish
because they'll have a passing game to
balance out the running game where
robinson was pretty much all that team
had last year so i think james robinson
was a great great choice by the jaguars
and hopefully the new coaching staff
will have the same faith in him that the
last coaching staff did and my
last bust i gotta go with justin
rohrwasser the fifth round kicker i
can't believe the patriots pissed away
sorry london a draft pick on a kicker
don't why is anybody look unless it's
ray guy or sebastian janikowski
why are you using a draft pick on a
kicker and then on top of it there was
some stuff some controversial stuff
about rorwasser in the three percenters
group and i didn't know the tattoo
baloney bs and it was a waste of a pick
by the new england patriots miles
oh it absolutely was and that was
embarrassing what he said oh i didn't
know what this tattoo meant come on man
if you're putting something on your body
permanently i think you probably have a
good idea of what it means after you get
to a certain age especially when you're
in high school i don't i don't believe
you when you start talking about oh i
don't i didn't know i had no idea give
me a break
my first tattoo and last tattoo if i
ever get one will be kirk cousins if and
when
he wins the super bowl mvp award which
uh i don't have to worry about finding a
tattoo parlor that can do a likeness of
kirk cousins anytime soon all right
quick look at the results here before we
take our break
miles had is his steals jordan fuller
justin herbert and legerius snead
i
had uh well miles bust he has henry
ruggs jeff acuta and jalen rieger then
from my picks steals justin jefferson
chase clay pool james robinson all
offense for me and then tuatanga byloa
jordan love and justin rohrwasser
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports